la noyade a commencé au premier grand
confinement le 15 accords et ça on le
premier premier confinement on n'a pas
eu des aides
puisqu'on avait le droit qu'au chômage
partiel et report des charges mais comme
moi j'ai un loyer de
29990 par trimestre ah ouais quand même
plus chez mon prêt qui est de 9000 euros
plus la redevance devait %
+ toutes les charges fixes qui fait que
quand nous avons repris au moins deux
arts sachant que quand on nous a fermé
le 15 mars j'avais 180000 euros de
trésorerie sur le compte
la franchise nous appelé en me disant
faut que vous payez tous les
fournisseurs sur toute la saison elle
battait son plein c'est en plein hiver
non on est autour de courchevel la
grande base morale enfin la ville
olympique où se trouvent toutes les
stations de ski nous a dit voilà il faut
payer tous les fournisseurs et comment
on a des factures des décalages à 30
jours j'avais reçu aussi la taxe la taxe
d'apprentissage qui est depuis de 9900
euros alors que les oraux apprentis dans
le restaurant mais dû à la surface de
mon restaurant la taxe d'apprentissage
c'est vous êtes menacés de 800 couverts
par jour à 150 le plus gros de tous le
monde le couvert que nous avons fait un
jour c'est plus c'est 893 parce qu'il ya
une âme il ya eu l'avalanche les
touristes se sont retrouvés coincés et
vous êtes transition et à 150 au grand
max donc c'est nourrir de 60% sinon
tourne normalement à entre 350 et 450
couverts
et quand on a repris au mois de juin
juste après premier confinement ben
j'avais plus de trésorerie parce qu'il
fallait que tout que je paye je venais
de prendre une le prêt garanti par
l'état de 115000 c'est tout ce qu'ils
avaient sur le compte et mais
malheureusement j'avais le loyer ben
10000 euros pour le mois de mars et
10000 euros pour le mois d'avril 10000
euros pour le mois de juin dix mille
euros pour voilà plus
le report des charges de se retrouver
avec plus de 50000 euros de charges
d'urssaf et ça commençait à alors
comment nager au jour d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la dette s'élève à combien
ces belges ou
s'élève à 1 million 18200
ce que je te réponds donc un mignon
d'aujourd'hui vous continuez à ou le
restaurant est toujours ouvert ouais
on est en plan de sauvegarde d'accord à
tubes système est un point de sauvegarde
selon lui conseille de notre avocat pour
pouvoir justement un million d'euros
donc la cccc une dette
18 parce qu'on a oublié les 8 10 ans
déjà c'est normal un million de vues
mais alors là nous avait entamé une
grève de la faim ouais encore au moins
deux jours huitième jour d'aujourd'hui
alors vous avez l'air fatigué web mais
très
très inquiet même jour de la grève de la
faim pourquoi ce que je suis laissé
tomber par la
franchise enseigne pendant ce
qu'est ce qu'il vous dise quand vous moi
j'aurais demandé mercredi
aujourd'hui on est juste pour bien que
les gens comprennent sans rentrer dans
des choses techniques parce que ça sert
à rien ce genre de restaurant il faut
faire cent mille euros hors taxes par
mois juste pour tout payer ses achats si
vous dépassez vous faites du bénéfice si
vous êtes en dessous vous commencez à
mourir
moi j'ai demandé à l'ansés de me baisser
loyer je fais quarante deux mille euros
de chiffre d'affaires 1 sur vous devez
payer 30 millions de francs de loyer
c'est par trimestre et messieurs je vous
donne juste le 15 du mois de décembre on
a fait 42 mille versions plus la taxe
tant sa quête à ma charge de 11000 euros
ce loyer 10000 puisse 11200 m'ont chargé
je m'en sors pas et aujourd'hui je
voudrais de la transparence aussi parce
qu'il faut comprendre une chose c'est
que notre les murs appartiennent à parce
que juste avant c'est un restaurant la
bouche qui est à la place de mon
emplacement
et dell'arte à faire un bail avec immo
bouche et nous ils nous ont fait un bail
de location j'ai aussi demandé de la
transparence de savoir parce que moi le
manque de bol le mandataire judiciaire
qui s'occupe de notre affaire c'est lui
qui a fait la liquidation du restaurant
la boucherie m'a dit le loyer est là il
est passé de tels prix à tel prix j'ai
demandé de la transparence
combien ambush fonds pea dell'arte des
raretés combien nous font payer mon
avocat écrit
administrateur judiciaire est écrire
tout le monde a écrit j'ai pas de
réponse le problème c'est si c'était de
tenir mon avis à mon avis et c'est de
ces des courriers et oui ils voient pas
votre détresse on est parti comme ça on
a un petit c'est un loyer at on
aujourd'hui on peut pas revenir en
arrière même si elle a créé ducobu qui
est passée par là et qui fait qu'on peut
faire trouver des aménagements
aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui ont
trouvé des aménagements avec avec l'or
avec avec on aurait dit il ya plein de
gens aussi dans vingt deux commerces qui
ont trouvé des arrangements
avec leurs frères pour pour trouver pour
que saab est cependant là les legs la
crise oui ce qui frappe énormément dans
votre dossier c'est qu'on a l'impression
que ni du côté de la franchise mais ni
des élus locaux ni du gouvernement ni de
personne parce que l'internement ils
sont les aides il aurait les mêmes les
élus locaux vous avez l'air totalement
seul non mais laissez nous encore à
s'annoncer au moins aider ils peuvent
aider mais à mon avis là il faut déjà qu
ils fassent des efforts sur le loyer oui
l'autre 6 qui a raison tigana d'antonio
là tu l'as tu n'as tu pas la franchir
les 100 matinale dans le fond je t'aime
beaucoup gillain mais là tu parles dans
le vent les élus locaux le gouvernement
ils ont déjà fait des aides là
aujourd'hui c'est c'est aujourd'hui
c'est là franchement foncier de se
baisser le loyer pour réessayer
peut-être de se retourner à quelqu'un
qui puisse quand même à avancer qu'ils
puissent essayer de gagner un petit peu
d'argent grâce à ça mais là les élus
locaux ça va prendre des semaines ça
c'est cette excuse moi je suis dans mais
ça c'est le frappe s'écrase tout fait
oui non juste un malheur à la franchise
allez allez quand même un responsable ce
qu'elle est au dessus de vous et je
pense que la franchise comme c'est le
cas pour plein de groupes ont pris des
gros z au moment du du coup
ça bah oui parce que tous les groupes
ont pris beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
l'effet pyramidale aurait dû vous
profiter un petit peu parce que on
comprend pas comment on a rien du tout
après après vont se dire après le
problème et je vous dis ils vont se dire
il ya énormément de franchise on a beau
j'aime beaucoup ont pu ses pizzas jeux
les sites adjacents sinon je décide
souvent 200 restaurants mais problème il
reste comme en affaires avec les autres
parce que ils vont rire tout le monde va
nous demander c'est ça aussi un
lorsqu'il vous répondre ça déjà sur le
restant c'est que depuis qui s'est passé
depuis que j'ai parce qu'il ya eu une
tentative de suicide de vendredi
on m'a retrouvé de justesse donc vous
avez vous avez tenté de me suicider
vendredi
ses lacets de l'axé un artiste un faux
rythme un mari formidable qui avait même
abandonné 7 au fond du trou comme des
solutions vous pouvez des solutions
répondent double peine non moi ce temps
elle a une histoire
sociale s'appelle victor et je suis une
fille qui n'a pas de diplôme ou je suis
pas là pour
qu'on ait pitié de moi cherche aucune
pitié elle est juste là pour que ça
une jeune fille qui était passé à 13 ans
en foyer je suis une passionnée de
cuisine ma vie c'est la cuisine
d'ailleurs ce qui m'a fait tenir pendant
le confinement si c'est comme ça qu'on
va découvrir découvrir découverte sur
instagram du ham et 1,07 et tout ça et
euh
moi j'étais un homme qui m'a violenté
pendant des années
sous restaurant c'était mais en plus
c'était ma j'étais alors votre avis
aujourd'hui je suis en train de tout
perdre mais je tiens à dire oh tu
espères c'est que le restaurant on avez
vous travaillé rien puisque car tenez le
respect envers ce
sens 800 couverts par jour donc ou pas
ça non mais voilà vous vous travaillez
très bien et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
voilà vous vous retrouvez comme ça moi
je pense que s'ils cherchent à passer
sur scène qui nous regardons bien
évidemment qu'à une personne des deux
pizzas des l'amener en dirigeante vous
avez su persuader su persuader que ils
peuvent pas rester insensible face à
votre témoignage et je suis sûr qu'ils
vont vous aider
si vous ont vu aujourd'hui donc il faut
garder espoir ah nan vraiment jusqu'où
vous dire que là ce qu'il fallait faire
comme chiffre d'affaires pour que ce
restaurant tombe bien c'est 1 million
250 mille le prix visionnaire par an
j'ai fait un million huit la première
année c'est magnifique après il ya des
histoires que je veux pas raconter
qu'ils sont arrivés j'ai vraiment pas eu
de chance
et enfin en sachant que le couple
apparaît seulement que notre avocat
s'est permis quand même de faire un
courrier à un autre notre bailleur en y
soumettant justement la régularisation
du loyer ou si l'on trouve à faire ça
nous met en demeure sourit jean